مع ارتفاع درجه حراره الارض يواجه مليارات
البشر المعتمدون على الارز في غذائهم
مشاكل عديده واضحت ازمه والمناخ مزعجه
بشكل خاص لصغار المزارعين الذين يملكون
القليل من الاراضي كما هو الحال بالنسبه
لمئات الملايين من المزارعين في اسيا فبعد
ان نجحت فيتنام بشكل مذهل في عام
واصبحت ثالثه اكبر مص مصدر للارز في
العالم بعد الهند وتايلاند نرى اليوم دولا
اسيويه اخرى كالصين تقول ان هتلر الامطار
الغزيره قد قلل من غله الارز على مدار
العشرين عاما الماضيه بينما حدث الهند من
صادرات الارز خوفا من ان لا يكفي المخزون
المحلي منه الاطعام شعبها ومن المتوقع ان
يتقلص انتاج ولا روز هذا العام في جميع
انحاء العالم الى حد كبير بسبب الطقس
القاسي التحديات الان مختلفه عن ما عليه
قبل خمسين عاما بعدما كان العالم بحاجه
الى انتاج المزيد من الارز لدرء المجاعه
اليوم ما خلق نظام الانتاج المكثف مشاكل
جديده بعدما استنفذ طبقات المياه الجوفيه
وهناك ايضا تغير مناخي قلبه ايقاع اشعه
الشمس والمطر الذي يعتمد عليه الارز كما
ان الارز يمثل بحد ذاته مشكله مناخيه اخرى
فهو مسؤول عما يقدر بنحو ثمانيه في المئه
من انبعاثات المثال العالميه
من عمان ينضم الينا الدكتور فاضل الزعبي
الخبير في الامن الغذائي بمركز جنيف
للدراسات والممثل السابق لمنظمه الفاو في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط دكتور ما تقييمكم لهذه
المشكله ما حجمها
شكرا جزيلا هذه المشكله ليست فقط على
الارز وانما على كامل المنتجات الغذائيه
واذا ما تحدثنا عن الارز وتاثر انتاجه
بفعل التغييرات المناخيه نجد ان تاثره
كبير جدا بسبب اعتماده الهائل على المياه
نحن نتحدث عن انخفاض في عام 2030 قد يصل
الى نسبه كبيره اكثر مما نحن فيه بسبب
الفيضانات
الهزات الموجوده اذا طلعنا لقدام شوي
ورحنا للعشرين خمسين نجد ان درجه الحراره
سوف ترتفع ما يقارب درجتين مئويه راح ينزل
وينخفض انتاجيه الرز ما يقارب الثلاثه
ارباع طن في كل هكتار اما في عام 2080
فراح ينزل الى 32% على سبيل المثال في
منطقه مثل الدلتا تايلند اذا هنالك خطر
على انتاج الرز في العالم هذا الخطر
تتمثل بما ذكرتموه في تقريركم نحن الان لا
يزيد ما يدخل سوق التجاره الدوليه من
الارز عن 53 مليون طن بالرغم من انه
الانتاج يصل الى
520 مليون طن طبعا مع اضافه ما هو موجود
في السوق العالمي من مخزونات وغيرها لذلك
هي مشكله كبيره جدا لكن دكتور فاضل الارز
ليس فقط ضحيه لتغير المناخي لكنه كذلك هو
يساهم في هذه المعضله اليس كذلك
طبعا لا يوجد اي منتج زراعي سواء كان
نباتي اي او حيواني الا له بصمه بيئيه
ويؤثر ويزيد من انبعاث الغازات
تحديدا الميثان ولكن هنا ياتي دور مع
نطالب به دائما مراكز البحوث من اجل
استنباط بذور جديده بذور عاليه الانتاجيه
مقاومه للحراره مقاومه للملوحه
مقاومه للجفاف تؤدي الى زياده الانتاجيه
يعني حاليا انتاج الهكتار من الارز يتراوح
في من ثلاثه ونصف طن الى الى سته طرف بعض
الدول هذه انتاجيه جدا ضعيفه اذا ما
تحدثنا عن الدول الرئيسيه اللي هي منتجه
للارز الهند واليابان والصين نجد ان الصين
في البذور المهجنه ساهمت في زياده
الانتاجيه الى وبالتالي التخفيف من البصمه
الوراثيه البيئيه يعني ما الحلول المطروحه
دكتور وصولا الى
2080 كما تفضلت وهل يمكن ايجاد بديل عن
الارز
هو هو الارز نفسه بديل يعني يعني القمح
الحبوب الاستراتيجيه الاساسيه بس خلينا
ننظر الى يعني حتى اجاوب على سؤالك الى
موضوعين مختلفين الموضوع الاول الانماط
الاستهلاكيه احنا بنتحدث عن ما يقارب معدل
استهلاك للفرد في العالم يصل 53 كيلوغرام
لكن في نفس الوقت تجد انه في اوروبا لا
يزيد المعدل عن ثمانيه كيلو جرام للفرد
بينما في اسيا يصل من 200 ل 300 كيلو جرام
فلك ان ترى بان الفقر وغياب الحبوب لديهم
والعادات الاستهلاكيه عادات الطعام
جعلت استهلاك الفرد يصل الى اكثر من 200
كيلو جرام في السنه هذا رقم هائل جدا هذه
من ناحيه فالعادات الغذائيه لابد من
تحولها الى انظمه مستدامه اكثر والنقطه
الاخرى هي
البحث وزياده البحث من اجل تاجيل وتعديل
الصفات الوراثيه
والبصمه الوراثيه للبذور حتى تنتج بمساحه
اقل بمياه اقل انتاج اعلى مقاومه للملوحه
كمان قليل في انبعاثات الغاز الميثان
ومش صديق للبيئه تاثيره اقل على البيئه
مما هو عليه الان دكتور فاضل الزعبي
الخبير في الامن الغذائي بمركز جنيف
الدراسات والممثل السابق لمنظمه فاو في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط شكرا لك